[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8
politique sur tv fil 78 je reçois
aujourd'hui aziz françois n'diaye c'est
le référent du mouvement marche dans les
yvelines avec lui nous verrons comment
son candidat emmanuel macron réagi face
à son nouveau statut de favori des
sondages
les dernières enquêtes d'opinion le
placent de plus en plus souvent devant
marine le pen et derrière cette
dynamique quelles sont les propositions
de celui à qui l'on a souvent reproché
son manque de programme dans soir aziz
françois n'diaye souaré bienvenue sur ce
plateau entrepreneur d'origine
sénégalaise vous êtes arrivé en france à
l'âge de 15 ans vous avez travaillé par
le passé aussi aux nations unies et
aujourd'hui vous êtes donc référents
dans les yvelines de ce mouvement en
marche
qu'est ce qui vous a décidé déjà a
heureusement à rejoindre pardon emmanuel
macron la volonté de changer la volonté
de changer avec quelqu'un qui portait
une vision qui regardaient la france
plutôt vers l'avenir que vers le passé
et surtout qui avait l'ambition de
redonner à chacun sa chance de réussir
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron et est
crédité de 25% d'intentions de vote au
premier tour quasiment autant voire plus
que marine le pen pour le front national
c'est un nouveau statut pour votre
candidat celui de favori de quasi favori
ça va changer la dynamique de campagne
non pas du tout vous savez nous depuis
le début on a toujours souhaité garder
notre lucidité quant aux sondages c'est
effectivement bien quand ils sont
favorables mais ce qui compte est
surtout c'est d'avoir le travail de
terrain et
et surtout la co construction de notre
projet est d'essayer de convaincre le
plus de français possible notre objectif
c'est d'avoir au moins 51 % de français
qui votent pour nous donc après la
dynamique positive qui s'enclenche
actuellement est très très très bonne
les est assez bien accueilli mais on
continuera exactement tel que nous
l'avions imaginé notre programme et
notre projet dans cette campagne
le front national néanmoins ce cas c'est
votre principal adversaire la présidente
du front national et l'ancien ministre
de l'économie obtiennent le même
pourcentage d'intentions de vote chez
les 18 34 ans 24% selon un récent
sondage harris
aujourd'hui c'est notre coeur de cible
principale oui parce qu'ils ont
carrément un projet dangereux pour le
payer un projet dangereux pour
l'intérieur et dangereux pour
l'extérieur
c'est à dire que la vision qu'ils ont dû
payer n'est pas la bonne
en tout cas à mon sens et au delà des
personnes qui les dirigeants du front
national c'est cette image et ce projet
qui
divise beaucoup plus qu'il ne rassemble
et ça séduit les jeunes les 18 34 ans
24% d'entre eux comme pour emmanuel
macron sont prêts à aller voter pour
marine le pen
oui parce que beaucoup de nos jeunes et
ça il faut longtemps il faut le regarder
beaucoup de jeunes sont désespérés
aujourd'hui moi c'est ce que je vous
disais si je me suis engagé parce que
effectivement l'avenir est sombre pour
nos jeunes et plutôt que de se refermer
encore plus sur nous nous avons choisi
nous en tout cas qui avons choisi de
suivre un modèle macron de prendre les
taureaux par les cornes et d'aller au
devant des français pour essayer de
d'imaginer un nouveau projet de
construire un nouveau projet marine le
pen à sa vision et elle impose à ses
militants nous avons construit nos
projets notre projet avec nos jeunes
donc ça ça change on va voir justement
quelques-uns des points de programme
dans un instant pendant la suite de ce
set 8 politique et puis vous nous direz
peut-être si emmanuel macron est un
candidat de gauche ou de droite s'il
faut trancher en attendant retour sur ce
déplacement dans les yvelines de
l'ancien ministre c'était le 7 mars
dernier aux mureaux un déplacement sur
la réussite scolaire mais aussi sur
l'emploi présent aux mureaux en début de
semaine emmanuel macron est venu
s'adresser aux habitants des quartiers
populaires et pour leur redonner un peu
d'espoir le chantier est vaste plus de
cent cinquante mille jeunes quittent
chaque année l'école sans qualification
dans certains quartiers comme ici on a
un tout qui est bien plus élevé donc je
pense que l'une des batailles forte
qu'il faut mener pour l'égalité des
chances c'est d'arriver à réduire de
façon forte 7
cette discrimination a parmi les
propositions du candidat dans marche des
effectifs allégés dans les zones en
éducation prioritaire avec un maximum de
douze élèves par classe vous avez des
élèves dont les parents accumule les
difficultés économiques ou sociales dans
les parents parfois ne maîtrisent pas
bien le français et qui ont donc besoin
d'un plus grand encadrement pour bien
maîtriser la lecture l'écriture et le
calcul
autre mesure généralisée la lutte contre
les discriminations ou encore accompagné
l'emploi dans les quartiers avec des
allègements de charge allant jusqu'à
quinze mille euros
les jeunes que j'ai pu entendre cet
après midi
l'ont confirmé lorsqu'on veut réussir au
sortir du quartier
il faut devenir footballeur acteur de
cinéma au comique maintenant il faut
pouvoir devenir professeur d'université
entrepreneurs cadres supérieurs reste à
convaincre les électeurs de ces
quartiers populaires dans cette ville
des mureaux l'abstention atteignait 31 %
au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle en 2012 contre 20%
seulement au niveau national l'objectif
de ce déplacement séduire justement
l'électorat populaire non c'était
surtout de présenter notre projet sur
l'éducation sur la culture parce que
c'est un enjeu fondamental c'est
vraiment le premier chantier que nous
avons dans notre projet et qui consiste
à véritablement redonner les chances à
chacun et corriger les inégalités
dès le départ et on sait c'est déjà dès
la maternelle que les choses se jouent
et bon c'était un symbole pour pouvoir
marquer son engagement fort sur ce sujet
là aujourd'hui le risque néanmoins pour
emmanuel macron ce n'est pas
d'apparaître trop à gauche peut-être on
voit aussi les ralliements de ces
derniers jours on pourrait citer
quelques-uns des ténors du ps
l'ancien maire de paris bertrand delanoë
et puis il ya des communistes aussi des
anciens communiste robert hue aussi
soutient emmanuel macron ce
qu'aujourd'hui emmanuel macron apparaît
trop à gauche et avec ce déplacement aux
mureaux ça va aussi renforcer cette
image vous savez nous a souvent reproché
d'être de gauche de droite et de nos
généraux ni de gauche ni de neil part
c'est emmanuel macron cohérent dans ce
qu'il dit lors de sa présentation de
candidature il a dit quelque chose qui
était assez intéressant il ne parle pas
aux français de gauche et ne parlent pas
français de droite que par le français
et le bon sens qui voudrait que
choisissent les politiques parce
qu'elles sont bonnes
cela nous conduit nous à pouvoir
rassembler toutes les forces qui sont à
gauche mais aussi à droite qui partagent
cette vision cohérente que le pays est
aujourd'hui un carrefour qui nécessitent
l'union des forces et il y a des idées
bonnes à gauche il y a des idées bonnes
à droite donc réunissant les et ici on
avancer et c'est ce qui se passe donc
ces personnalités de gauche qui
n'auraient qu'il nous rejoigne il faut
après avoir regardé notre
j'ai notre programme on a été fortement
compliqué il faut pas l'oublier sur
l'absence de programmes notamment alors
que aujourd'hui une fois qu'on a regardé
le programme on se rend compte que tout
ce qui est dedans été déjà annoncées
rien à 126 en des propositions qui ont
été faites dans ce programme la moitié
sont proches des propositions qui
avaient été faites par françois hollande
lors du dernier adieu dernier de la
dernière élection en rénovation
thermique réduction des délais sur les
procédures d'asile baisse du coût du
travail formation des chômeurs est ce
que c'est surprenant cette reprise de
programmes d'une bonne partie du
programme
l'étrange ce n'est pas une reprise c'est
le fruit de notre réflexion collective
et surtout du travail de terrain qui a
été fait ce qui a été remonté par le
comité locaux mais il faut pas oublier
que françois hollande dans son programme
il y avait des choses bien ici justement
une partie de ce quinquennat a été
immobilisé c'est parce que les frondeurs
ont empêché ses gouvernements successifs
devrait pour le bien du pays et c'est le
piège dans lequel nous n'avons pas voulu
tomber en faisant les primaires de
gauche notamment parce que tout
simplement aujourd'hui il y a dans
chaque de ces partis à droite et à
gauche des gens qui ne sont plus
d'accord sur rien et le fait de passer
par des primaires et on ne le voit on le
voit aujourd'hui vous conduit dès que
vous êtes élu à ne plus pouvoir
gouverner parce que les uns sont contre
les autres donc nous sommes cohérents
nous avons repris effectivement les
bonnes idées qui sont remontés mais qui
sont aussi l'incarnation de sa vision et
à partir de là nous concerne nous avons
construit un projet cohérent et je pense
que ces six chantiers parce que vous
avez nommés les différentes mesures mais
il y a six chantiers qui sont
prioritaires et sur lesquels on veut
s'engager
il s'agit pas de faire un catalogue
beaucoup nous ont fait des catalogues
dans le passé et n'ont jamais été tenues
nous nous avons six chantiers et c6
chantignole nous allons aller au bout de
ces deux de ses projets et parmi les
différentes propositions il ya cette
mesure qui a fait beaucoup parler 80%
des français exonérés de taxe
d'habitation va en parler avec nicolas
kirillovitch qui va nous rejoindre
[Musique]
en partenariat avec les surligneurs ce
site internet fondé par des membres de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
qui vérifie les fondements juridiques
des propositions des candidats nous
allons étudier certains points de
programme au cours de chacune des
éditions 17,8 politique cela s'appelle
du légal est chez king bonsoir nicolas
bonsoir et on va parler de cette
proposition qui a fait beaucoup parler
celle de cet abattement cette taxe
d'habitation
80% des français qu'il ne paierait plus
oui d'ici 2020 si emmanuel macron et
élus soient aussi quatre français sur
cinq qui sont potentiellement concernées
c'est donc une mesure importante pour
les électeurs mais pour les communes
aussi puisque c'est elle qui perçoivent
directement ces taxes d'habitation dont
elle fixe le taux si emmanuel macron
applique cette proposition c et 10
milliards en moins dans les caisses des
villes 10 milliards qui seraient en
revanche tout de suite compensé par
l'état c'est la promesse du candidat en
marche
on parle alors d'une dotation et non
plus non plus d'une ressource propre
en gros les collectivités n'y perdrait
pas au change et les français seraient
gagnants ans selon le candidat emmanuel
macron est ce que c'est une mesure qui
sera appliquée applicable en tout cas
alors c'est justement là que ça se
complique un petit peu cette proposition
pourrait être recalée par le conseil
constitutionnel car potentiellement
contraire à la constitution la
constitution qui indiquent précisément
dans la de ses articles que les recettes
fiscales vous le voyez à l'écran que les
recettes fiscales et les autres
ressources propres des collectivités
territoriales doivent représenter une
part déterminante de l'ensemble de leurs
ressources
or si la taxe d'habitation est compensée
par une dotation de l'état comme le veut
emmanuel macron il ne s'agira plus d'une
ressource propre et ses ressources
propres pourraient donc ne plus
représenter une part déterminante
c'est un petit peu compliqué je le
conçois pour les précisions écouter
justement vincent couronne fondateur du
site internet lé seul ignore qui s'est
penchée sur cette question précisément
la constitution nous disent l'article
72-2 de la constitution que l'impôt les
ressources propres doivent avoir une
part déterminante dans les ressources
des collectivités locales
aujourd'hui les ressources propres c'est
environ cinquante deux pour cent des
collectivités locales
donc c'est une part déterminante
si demain macro enlève 80 % de taxe
d'habitation on tomberait probablement
autour de 40% de ressources propres pour
les collectivités locales
donc est ce que le conseil
constitutionnel va estimer que c'est
encore une part déterminante en termes
de ressources propres
ou est-ce qui va considéré au contraire
que ça n'est plus suffisant et que l'on
ne peut pas exonérer 80% des ménages de
la taxe d'habitation donc wilfried en
résumé c'est une mesure qui est
applicable
il reste à savoir ce que veut dire
réellement ce mot déterminant inscrit
dans la constitution et la réponse à
cette question je ne l'est pas c'est le
constituent le conseil constitutionnel
et si c'est moi qui la merci nicolas on
vous retrouvera à chacune des éditions
du 7 8 politique en partenariat donc
avec les surligneurs de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
pour faire du légal checking aziz
conçois votre réaction
moi je m'arrêterai surtout à courre pas
sur le terme ressources propres mais sur
le terme ressources tout quoi je ne
pense pas que la taxe d'habitation soit
l'essentiel de l'assiette des ressources
propres les communes où plusieurs types
de deux d'origine de recettes et la taxe
d'habitation est clairement l'un des
impôts locaux les plus inégaux parce que
aujourd'hui vous avez dans certaines
communes riches une taxe d'habitation
très faibles alors que dans les communes
dites
moins riche on dira vous avez des taxes
d'habitation qui sont très élevés donc
c'est une injustice qu'il faut corriger
selon que vous soyez dans un territoire
avec des entreprises riches en nombre et
en j'allais dire en personnalité vous
paierez moins de taxe d'habitation
or on le sait ce sont dans les zones
désertiques que qu'il ya le plus de
difficultés pour les français à assumer
cette taxe d'habitation
donc il s'agit de revenir au niveau des
classes moyennes à quelque chose qui
soit beaucoup moins inégal et qui
permettra aussi aux français d'avoir un
peu plus de pouvoir d'achat
néanmoins des collectivités locales
nicolas l'expliquer aussi ont tous à
leurs recettes
on ne touche pas la recette on transfère
à l'état le financement de ses recettes
la audrey de cette partie l'adversaire
sachant que nous prendrons comme revenu
de base l'année 2016 pour l'attitude de
nombreuses communes c'est que ça se
transformerait en dotation et on sait
qu'aujourd'hui a beaucoup de dotation
qui vont vers la commune qui sont
fortement baisse qu alors là c'est elle
qui fixe le taux donc celle qu'on
finalement le choix de fixer leurs
propres taux et donc d'avoir les
recettes qu'elle souhaite aussi la
qualité de beaucoup de communes nommé il
n'y a pas d'inquiétude à avoir parce que
l'état financera à l'euro près ce qu'il
y à ces queues monstres à vizille ans
qu'il n'y ait pas de tour de passe-passe
pour que certaines communes augmente sur
l'année 2007 par exemple drastiquement
une fois que l' annonce a été faite
certains sont tentés d'augmenter leur
taxe d'habitation en disant oh moi ça
nous donnera de la marche non on prendra
la référence de l'année 2016 qui est
déjà passé et qui nous permettra d'avoir
quelque chose de plus crédibles et
cohérentes qui correspondra on le
suppose à la réalité des choses
mais l'état financera et financera à
l'euro près il n'y a aucune inquiétude
match et le 7-8 politique se poursuit à
présent nous allons passer un nouveau
rendez vous
[Musique]
autre rendez-vous dorénavant dans ce set
8 politique la campagne vu par les
électeurs pour ceux qui vont se
prononcer parce qu'ils vont se prononcer
pardon dans l'isoloir une profession une
catégorie socioprofessionnelle
aujourd'hui elle les agricultures
quelques jours après elle le salon de
l'aviculture qu'attendent-ils c'est un
reportage signé nicolas landry je
m'appelle xavier vraiment j'ai 45 ans je
suis exploitants agricoles céréales à
chevreuse dans les yvelines
j'ai repris l'exploitation de mon père
en 1995
eh bien je subis d'une part les aléas
climatiques ça c'est une chose qui est
naturel dans notre métier mais je suis
aussi les variations de prix importantes
on va dire qu'avant les dernières
réformes de la pac
on avait des prix qui étaient
relativement stabilisée et fixé
l'ouverture des marchés à
l'international fait que maintenant nos
prix varient beaucoup
en fait j'aimerais que certaines normes
soient abordées et en tout cas discuter
avec le avec la profession ce qui est un
petit peu le problème
on a le sentiment que on nous impose des
obligations qui viennent d'une
hiérarchie qui viennent de très très
haut avec des gens qui ne sont pas en
phase avec la réalité du terrain
[Musique]
le bilan des cinq années précédentes en
terme d'agricole s'est résumée à une
agriculture en faillite
donc je vois pas comment celui qui le
remplacerait pourrait faire mieux
puisque l'on reprend à peu près les
mêmes idées dans certains extrêmes on
nous parle de la sortie de l'union
européenne je pense que l'agriculture si
elle résiste pour l'instant c'est parce
qu'elle a un échelon européen mais je
trouve que finalement l'agriculture on
en parle très peu alors que ça fait
quand même partie du paysage c'est
quelque chose d'important
il ya une vraie véritable crise aussi
bien dans le domaine des céréales que
dans le domaine de l'élevage
il y as je pense des choses à faire
j'aimerais qu'on parle un petit peu de
nous aux agriculteurs par dont emmanuel
macron alors dit qu est ce que ça fait
partie aussi des axes de campagne pour
votre candidat ça nous a occupés tout le
mois de février
nous sommes allés partout dans les
territoires écoles notamment et il a
tenu un rassemblement à saint priest où
il a affirmé un certain nombre de
mesures notamment la nécessité de monter
en gamme pour nos agriculteurs
on le sait aujourd'hui il nous faut
gagner en compétitivité produit de façon
à pouvoir être beaucoup plus compétitive
sur moi c'est international pouvoir être
beaucoup plus fort à l'export mais aussi
une réorganisation de nos organisations
d'agriculteurs pour qu'elles soient en
mesure de mieux négocier et se défendre
face aux grands distributeurs
donc ils sont clairement dans notre au
coeur de notre de notre projet de
création d'un nouveau modèle nouveau
modèle économique
français et ils ont un rôle à jouer il
dit souvent que les paysans font le pays
c'est une réalité bon il y a aujourd'hui
une nécessaire montée en gamme et une
nécessaire réorganisation de ce secteur
qui est un chantier très importante mais
sur lequel nous allons effectivement
beaucoup plus que l'europe est souvent
critiqué par les agriculteurs cette
politique agricole commune
il faut la réviser et revoir je pense
pas que ce soit l'europe qui est en
cause je pense que l'europe au contraire
est une force et on le voit face à
certains ensembles l'europe et le le le
niveau par lequel nous pourrons mieux
nous défendre ce qui est en cause c'est
notre capacité à identifier nos intérêts
et avoir une stratégie claire je je je
parlais tout à l'heure de la montée en
grade
il est clair que dans pour la transition
écologique pour le passage au bio il ya
toute une série de secteurs sur lesquels
nous français nous sommes quand même en
très bonne position mais sur lesquelles
on n'a pas suffisamment investi et nous
nous avons un plan de 15 milliards pour
investir dans ce domaine là et de nos
inscrits à nos agriculteurs à monter en
gamme parce qu'on pense que c'est là où
ça se joue vous savez il n'ya pas de
secret la création de valeur ajoutée
notamment et surtout dans ce secteur-là
sera déterminante pour les années à
venir
le 7-8 politique se poursuit toujours
consacré à la présidentielle vous vous
en doutez nous parlions du mouvement en
marche on va regarder un peu plus en
détails ce qui s'est passé ces derniers
jours du côté de la gauche mais de la
droite aussi de la gauche tout d'abord
au moment où nous enregistrons cette
émission benoît hamon lui a eu le feu
vert nathalie arthaud aussi à droite on
pourrait citer françois fillon et de
nicolas dupont aignan ils ont eu le feu
vert du conseil constitutionnel avec les
500 parrainages
benoît hamon que vous voyez à l'image on
l'a évoqué lui à elle du mal à faire
l'union une partie des socialistes ayant
choisir on disait avec vous en êtes
françois emmanuel macron d'autres
hésitent encore écouter catherine tasca
sénatrice des yvelines
moi je suis socialiste et je resterai
socialiste jusqu'au bout
je ne prendrai pas une part active dans
la campagne de monsieur hamon mais je ne
change pas je ne change pas aisément de
maison pourquoi départ hâtives vous
n'apportez pas votre temps des neiges a
mentionné c'est pas tranché encore
l'union est fait en revanche avec europe
ecologie les verts pour le candidat
socialiste un accord a été trouvé la
réaction à présent d'olivier paréja il
est responsable dans les yvelines de la
formation écologiste
pour être clair le le fait qu elle
benoît montre sortie de la primaire du
parti socialiste change absolument tout
nous étions pour une rupture avec la
politique du gouvernement actuel donc
pour nous venoit -47 cette rupture et
jean luc mélenchon dans son programme
aussi des choses et d'écologistes donc
il ya peut-être moyen de trouver ce
socle qui nous rassemble plutôt que
d'insister sur les divisions
on a une grosse attente le feu qui a été
négociée soit retenue et continue à
vivre contrairement à ce qui s'est passé
avec l'accord qui avait été passé en
2001 avec le parti socialiste benoît
hamon qui a durci le ton il dit que
emmanuel macron en manque du plus
élémentaire sens de la justice sociale
que son projet peut accélérer la montée
en puissance du front national parce
qu'il n'a rien d'autre à dire maintenant
aujourd'hui à un problème c'est que il
n'ose pas assumer ce qu'il est et en
même temps il veut faire payer un appel
du pied à la gauche de la gauche il sait
pas tenable et on le voit ça ça se
fissure de partout
moi j'aimerais revenir un peu à ce que
disait catherine tasca
on voit bien la difficulté qu'a toute
cette partie droite la gauche à savoir
qu'ils ne se reconnaissent pas du tout
cas qui avait soutenu un manuel valls
pendant la primaire
exactement idéologiquement elle est très
proche de ce que nous représentons
programme mais prise au piège pas parler
j'allais dire la prison dorée de des
primaires de gauche ils sont dans une
situation où ils n'osent pas à les
soutenir
emmanuel macron sous peine d'être accusé
de trahir leur parole donnée mais en
même temps ils peuvent pas soutenir
benoît hamon parce qu'il ne correspond
pas du tout idéologiquement alors
philosophique donc c'est vrai et
ablement ce qui prouve qu'on est arrivé
au bout de ce système est aujourd'hui ce
que nous proposons c'est de
et toutes celles et ceux qui sont en
capacité de pouvoir relever le défi du
pays sans regarder les accords partisans
si on cumule les voix de jean luc
mélenchon alors certes c'est des
mathématiques politique c'est pas une
science exacte mais les voix de jean-luc
mélenchon et celle de benoît hamon et
rivalise avec votre candidat est avec
marine le pen
on n'est pas loin des 25 % aussi sans
doute mais entre les deux on a vu il ya
une fracture qui sera difficile à
franchir
il ya une pétition en ligne malgré tout
qui demande le rapprochement de ces
candidats de la gauche et des candidats
aussi dits citoyens notamment la
candidature de charlotte marchandise
c'est l'initiative la primaire point org
qui l'a désigné après une consultation
en ligne son représentant été récemment
sur le plateau écoutez nous sommes de
simples citoyens qui souhaitons nous
engager donc en politique nous trouvons
que c'est normal de s'occuper des
affaires de la cité et de notre pays
cependant nous ne
ne nous retrouvons pas dans les partis
politiques traditionnels
nous voyons d'ailleurs ces partis
politiques plus comme des obstacles à la
démocratie comme des outils pour la
faire vivre
justement justement dans donc la
primaire - org
nous avons trouvé nous le pensons donc
un outil qui permet de désigner des
représentants des citoyens des
représentants donc du peuple
d'une manière plus acceptable d'un point
de vue démocratique nous parlions de la
gauche que se passe-t-il à droite après
le feuilleton judiciaire qui secoue les
républicains les défections sont
nombreuses mais on croit encore à
l'union sacrée ainsi et xavier bertrand
étaient dans les yvelines le 9 mars
dernier aux côtés de david douillet le
sujet signé nicolas kirillovitch
la marseillaise en guise de conclusion
d'une réunion publique une habitude en
campagne présidentielle mais les paroles
prennent forcément une signification
particulière après des semaines agitées
pour le camp des républicains au bord de
l'implosion il y a quelques jours la
droite joue désormais la carte du
rassemblement derrière le candidat
fillon tout le monde a conscience que si
on veut réformer notre pays est allé ans
dans le bon sens le seul qui peut à le
faire c'est françois fillon donc de huy
et toute la famille est réunie
on se doit d'être assemblés dans notre
pays
voilà parce que si la droite française
n'est pas présente à cette élection
présidentielle
le jeu démocratique ne pourra pas être
des fourmis pour cette réunion publique
organisée à plaisir avec xavier bertrand
et valérie pécresse présidente de région
notamment défendu le projet françois
fillon sécurité justice lutte contre le
terrorisme des thèmes de la droite dure
qui ont convaincu les 500 militants
présents pour l'occasion
moi j'ai fait un choix pour sauver la
france pour avoir un programme et une
personnes qui sont en adéquation est
absolument aucun est ce qui est
important c'est un programme c'est sa
personnalité
et puis bon
il ya présomption d'innocence et moi je
pense que cet anneau n'étonne un peu
plus de quarante jours du premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle emmanuel
macron et marine le pen ont été
également les cible de nombreuses
attaques de la part des élus
républicains
les candidats dans marché du front
national qui font désormais la course en
tête dans les sondages devant françois
fillon
ceux qui ne se retrouvent pas à droite
sont les bienvenus aussi des côtés de
rang marche
ceux qui ne se retrouvent pas à droite
ont la possibilité de voter pour un
candidat sérieux et crédibles qui est
menée loi kron ce qui est sûr nous c'est
ce qu'on dit depuis le départ il y aura
pas d'accord de partie marc compte tous
ceux qui souhaitent soutenir sa
candidature hi-fi se retrouve surtout
dans nos valeurs sont clairement les
miens les centristes est ce que dans les
yvelines pour cibler spécifiquement
notre département vous discuté avec les
représentants du des annonces et nous ne
discutons pas uniquement mais ils sont
avec nous aujourd'hui on a pas mal de
d'élus et de jeunes udi quinon qui nous
ont rejoints et qui sont très très très
actifs et les jeunes udc du département
qui ont tous démissionné justement de
leurs différentes fonctions et prenons
un parti qui vous ont trop beaux jours
au jeu et qui jouent un rôle très actif
au sein de notre mouvement dans les
yvelines
merci d'avoir été avec nous au cours de
cette demi heure du 7-8 politique qui se
referme donc aujourd'hui prochain numéro
ce sera le 24 mars invité françois
simeoni responsable départemental du
front national on se retrouve bientôt
sur ted et fils
[Musique]